[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting
we're having a little listening party
congratulations Rhett
it's finally happened your freaking
album is out I mean not when we're
recording this but yes when you're
listening I'm in celebration mode uh
James in the shame uh Rhett's Alter Ego
where he plays music that is
sincerely
symptomatized and sincerely great it's
my pleasure to sit here and listen to it
with you and kind of talk through each
song you know yeah this is like a
listening party I'm gonna take more I'm
gonna take a you know a journalistic
Approach at times okay okay I have a I
have a notepad here whereas I'm going to
maybe make some jottings
that then um
will will lead to you exposing the truth
behind
Behind these songs but uh but also I
just got all the music off of a
royalty-free site and just sang over it
you want me to admit that finally okay
up first go for it
um
so again the album is human overboard
the whole album is out now wherever you
listen to your music what we're going to
be doing is listening to all 11 Tracks
in album order
uh we're actually gonna as you're
listening to this you're not gonna hear
the full track because we're not going
to just play the full song for every
single song we're going to listen to the
full song so we we might reference
something that is in one of the full
songs that you didn't hear because we're
going to play like a portion of the song
to give you the feel and the vibe so you
can listen to the album on your own time
um
so that's that's what we'll do
and I wanted to do I'm actually going to
take these out because I'm actually not
listening to anything right now and it
makes my voice sound weird yeah I
already had to do that um
I'm gonna do what they used to do
in the old movies
and I'm gonna do the credits first
because I don't want to just put the
people that I want to think at the end
and you're just like I've heard the
whole album and then I'm done and so you
might want to Fat yeah I mean if you
decide you want to finish what I'm
saying you might decide that you want to
fast forward but don't because the one
of the coolest things about this whole
project
is has been the collaborative nature
of it coming to fruition and being what
it is it's you know I had a lot of
people who made me
uh sound the way that I sound and and
shape these songs
and shape the whole project and I that I
collaborated with on different parts of
it so I want to just start by thanking
them
uh
do you have a list I do first of all I
want to just start with now you haven't
won an award I just want to clarify uh
yeah yeah no I haven't maybe you will
hey well okay well it kind of will work
like I'm just saying typically you think
people did the daily record this is the
daily record is going to be best album
of the Year from a guy who used to have
a studio in Lillington
yeah you could get a chamber of commerce
award at least for this thing no I'm
just saying this these are the people
who made this project what it is shout
them out man so first of all the person
who played the biggest role Derek Furman
my producer who of course we got to know
love me some Derek we got to know
through Britain uh Link's cousin because
he was recording some stuff with him and
he's done some stuff from the mythical
Society for our you know our collabs
that we do over there the vinyl that we
do and you know the reason I decided to
go with Derek on this project isn't
because he had ever done any country or
folk music he's a pop guy
but because
he is so committed to making things work
and he was so committed to learning the
process and he learned he like he told
me multiple times I'm learning so much
about this type of music as we you know
as we make these songs and again the way
that it worked is
I would write the lyrics in the music
basically me and a guitar singing to a
certain beat the BPM
that's a beat per minute yeah and I
would send him that and that is the
backbone of everything that that he
didn't then create it was one beat per
minute that would be slow sorry go ahead
it's like it was whale music yeah
uh but then he would kind of send back
because again I have another job
actually several other jobs that I do
here at mythical so this is a has been a
side project and a hobby so I haven't
been able to devote the kind of time
that typical people
typically people devote to this kind of
thing so I would send him these demos
and then he would come back with like
he's like hey here's what I'm thinking
about the Baseline this is kind of what
I'm hearing in a drum Groove kind of
thing that then we would then send off
to other people to add their pieces it
was like so collaborative and so many
steps to finally get to the final song
but he was the one that was guiding that
process to kind of be like here's what
the he would send me a bunch of options
and he would send me but really it was
his ear and his Instinct with these
different musicians that he hired that
made these songs go from a guy playing
something on a guitar to what you end up
hearing on the album and he was just so
intimately involved in making it what it
is so I just wanted to start big thanks
to Derek Furman
you would be lucky to have him as a
producer on your project yeah a lot of
people they don't really you know if if
you've not experienced it sometimes it's
hard well in hip-hop it's actually you
know that a lot more credit is given to
producers but like growing up listening
to music I really didn't think about the
producer's role and so everything you
just described is not necessarily
something
that is just because
of your situation and all the different
directions that you've been pulled in
that you needed to like give it over to
Derek or something I think you're
describing what a good producer does
which is oh yeah something that I didn't
appreciate at first and like helping
bring shape and cohesion and specific
direction to songs that are in their
rawest form and also a producer can make
a break
a song entirely and he's a musical a
great producer is also a musical
director somebody who's like hey uh
let's try that again and give me a
little bit more softness or give me a
little bit more emotion in that or you
know even a couple of times this didn't
happen on every song but there were a
couple of songs where he was like ah the
phrasing of that part is kind of bumping
me and we would sit there and we would
try to figure out like oh I'm gonna use
this syllable I'm gonna use this word
here and like locking it in so there's
not things that bump you throughout the
album so he was integral in that process
another person that did so much
Alex Straley the first time I talked
about Alex when we talked about believe
me
I mispronounced his last name I think I
said straw oh straightly
so Alex is just a he's a
multi-instrumentalist musician here in
California in Los Angeles uh who's in a
couple of bands but he's also kind of a
session guitar guy
and
he and Derek knew him you know
originally with so much like we wanted
to do pedal steel we wanted to do
obviously like country sounding guitar
and places we wanted banjo we wanted
mandolin
he Alex did all of that so originally it
was gonna be like Derek was like I gotta
have to talk to some contacts to get
some Nashville guys to do these
authentic country parts
and then he's like and then he didn't
really have any luck with that but he's
like hey I I know a guy in in Pasadena
Alex Straley who he's got all these old
guitars and old instruments like the
pedal steel is a 1946 instrument wow uh
that's not even a pedal steel it's a
multi-cord it's it's something it's like
a predecessor to a pedal steel really
that he engineered to be able to
uh you know because basically the way
the multi-cord you would hit a pedal and
it changes the whole chord that's being
played right he found a way to make it
where he can he like he does all this he
manipulates all these instruments and
stuff and
he basically engineered this thing to
make it into a pedal steel but that's
not technically what you would see as a
as a lap pedal steel oh a pedal steel
you play the chords with your feet with
your feet so pedal how many pedals are
there is it like an organ I don't know
what I haven't seen it yeah because when
they're playing that these striking
these were these were remote in some
senses I think yeah they're like on a
they're like on a live session with each
other that I could tune into while I was
doing my job but I wasn't there when
there's actually doing it right did you
ever meet Alex in person
At All by the time this podcast is being
recorded I I will because no no but we
are recording it podcast is live because
I wanted to go out with Derek and Alex
because they were the two like you know
they're they're all you have plans to
meet him but you still have not met I
want to do a celebration dinner with
them so yes we will have done that uh
but anyway Alex is again he's not a
country guy he just has great instincts
and I think it ended up bringing this
awesome vibe to a lot of the so the way
that I would describe it is if you are
impressed by guitar that you hear on the
album it's him not me right I can play
you know I'm I'm proficient especially
as a song writer when it comes to I can
do what I need to do on a guitar to
write a song and to kind of keep a
rhythm and do a picking pattern that
kind of thing
but like if you're impressed by it
chances are it was him doing it all
right who else you got uh Gunner Olsen
did all the percussion and all the drums
it's a good name for someone to do
something and this is just a dude who's
a session drummer in New York who has
worked with a bunch of big stars he did
all he did all a percussion on
Springsteen's uh Western Stars album
he's divorced with Miley Cyrus and you
know a bunch of people who are more
talented and more prolific than me uh
but again Derek is is it knows him and
he knew he could do this kind of like
Americana Style
and he nailed it so thanks to Gunner
I'll talk about more musicians once we
get into individual track but again I
want to talk I want to thank Anna Weber
who took all the pictures for the whole
thing like so any pictures where I look
like I might be a legitimate uh artist
or feeling shame yes while the picture's
being taken that was Anna Weber thanks
to Anna Weber the album art uh for the
album you know the meat in the water on
the front
that was illustrator Greg Newbold who
painted that
digitally painted that uh and I don't
think he's done much Alamar he's just
like a legit like artist painter who
does like Gallery work and stuff and uh
it's cool we you know Cara helped me
find him online and he did an incredible
job Kendrick Kidd who we used to work
with a long time ago back in the day he
designed the James and the shame logo
and then okay and then Kara uh Cara
Powers uh our assistant Kendrick
designed the first Good Mythical Morning
logo
yeah yeah yeah see and uh uh the Rhett
and Link logo
that has us we look like one chess piece
like two faces facing yeah the two heads
the one head and two faces yeah he also
did that
yeah so and then Kara Powers our
assistant who spent a lot of her time
working on this with me and finding
these talented people so it was just so
cool because
I just you know we haven't done anything
like this in a while because we have
this incredible team here at mythical
that we have an idea
and the team implements that idea but
this was kind of more the old school way
we used to work which is like hey we
need somebody let's find somebody online
that we like their work and we can just
collaborate with them yeah it was really
cool just when you bring somebody into a
process and they make something into
what it is so
uh well without further Ado we can start
listening to the song but you know what
might as well just talk quickly
um so we don't break up the album let's
talk about we're still good we're still
good we're still good uh this is the
party game from mythical for all your
friends to get together
you play a card it has a blank it's a
crazy scenario that then everybody
submits what they think should fill in
the blank the person chooses what makes
that scenario
horrible and then everybody needs to
write a positive spin saying we're still
good to turn into something positive so
it's like it's very fulfilling it's good
for your soul it'll make you laugh it
also help you reframe things
if you're in a
that therapy which is important I think
it's important reframing language stoic
philosophy
um yeah we we heard from a therapist
that said they were using it
in that context
we're still good available by amazon.com
it took me a while to figure out uh what
the album order is going to be and
actually this process right now is
committing me to the album order
oh okay well okay yeah I gave some input
into this so I'm curious I uploaded them
I uploaded the songs yesterday I could
technically I have not listened to them
in album order before now
um believe me the first single has been
out we've already listened to it once
but uh it's gonna we gotta listen to it
again all right here we go
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
now if you love life
I don't think it's true
[Music]
say my heart was never true that might
say more about you
[Music]
love it first single we you know we've
already talked about this one when when
the scene came out so I don't want to
retread any of that ground but we have
the benefit of like you you've heard the
most fan feedback from this song because
it's been out the longest you know
what's so one I'm kind of curious about
like what's what's that experience been
like what are our our people are people
getting it are people you know what is
it what kind of conversations is it
leading to
because most of the people who are
listening at this point listening to my
music are people who are already fans of
us
uh
we're getting like the the reaction to
this type of music from people who are
just fans of us which
doesn't mean they're fans of country
music now we have a subset of mythical
Beast who are fans of country music but
the most common first of all the
response has been so positive from a
musical standpoint I'll talk about you
know thematically that response but
surprise you know people are like yeah
oh you know I didn't people do this kind
of thing all the time right and it's a
Trope it's a Trope for if you're doing
this one thing in entertainment you're
like you always just think I can also do
music you know
I think the thing that is a reminder to
people podcast is the new version of
that but yeah yeah yeah uh is that we
started our career as musicians so
that's actually this is going back to
the basics for me in a lot of ways the
first thing we ever did professionally
as entertainers
it was music based but people are still
surprised because you know they come
they come on board at certain points and
yeah right it's always like what you you
do this I mean we we've had fans of our
music for years who are like yeah what
about a serious album so it kind of
scratches that itch for them yeah but
there's a lot of people who yeah it's
like they never knew what sound it would
be that it would be so country the most
common response is I'm not a fan of
country music or I hate country music
but I love this
and it's interesting I'm seeing the same
exact thing because you know when we're
recording this I just put where we're
going the second single out the same
exact reaction uh in terms of I don't
like country but I like this song too
and a lot of people are now saying hey
it's not that you don't like country
music it's that you've been listening to
the wrong country music you've been
listening to radio country music you've
been listening to what's popular on the
radio of nobody listens to the radio
anymore but you know what I'm saying
it's a certain type of sound yeah yeah
it's all these songs about trucks and
you know God and Country or whatever and
it's like this is not this is not that I
think people it's like oh you actually
do like
broadly country folk Americana however
there's multiple ways to describe it
yeah you're turning people on to it
um what I wanted to a shout out a couple
of moments
well the one lyric early on when you say
because the one I gave you said that
that ain't it
I like that lyric because it's you've
got the U which is the end of one
sentence the beginning of the next
sentence right am I hearing that right
no the one I gave you
said that that ain't it no it's because
the one I gave you said that out
oh but you can hear it that way I always
I always hear it I always hear it more
closely also it makes sense that way I
gave it to you you said well I mean
that's what I'm saying yeah it is what
you're saying but you actually didn't do
what I thought you did
no I didn't have time to change it it's
the one I gave
you said that ain't it yeah that makes
more sense but it's also the one I gave
you
you said that ain't it that needs to be
how you you need to take credit for that
okay okay I did it on purpose what about
um you know in the chorus or
you say my heart was never true
that may say more about you
is that the type of thing that it speaks
for itself or
I'm curious
what what does this say about people
well
I don't know if that's for them to
figure out okay yeah but but I I think
that you know the reason that this is
the first song
is because it's is what I explained
before musically I think it kind of sets
its own but thematically like the album
order more than the musical progression
I I leaned into the Thematic progression
of like if
you were to sit down with me and I were
to begin talking to you about my
deconstruction which is not even really
something that I want to do unless
somebody starts asking me about it
um especially now I don't
you know
I'm not interested in changing people's
minds as much as I may have been at an
earlier point but
like what is the process that I would
that I would lead you through as I was
kind of trying to explain myself right
this is kind of this is obviously a
super self-indulgent project on multiple
levels but also just the fact that I
think I got something to say and that
you should listen to it right in there
as self-indulgent but if I did if I am
talking to you regardless of where
you're at on the spectrum of spiritual
deconstruction Christianity whatever
this kind of sets the tone of saying
the point of this is not for you to
agree with what I'm saying the point is
just listen if somebody is going to tell
you about their spiritual experience
take their word that they're the closest
to it as they can possibly be and that
they're being honest with you and what
they're saying
and so if your perspective at the end of
the day is that oh you never were a
Christian and you may be committed to
that because of some theological
perspective that you have
again that says more about you in that
instance if you think that I wasn't a
Christian that's not actually there's
nothing about me that demonstrates that
I wasn't a Christian
it's you and your commitment to a
specific ideology that makes you see me
in a certain way
So when you say my heart was never true
this says a lot more about you than it
does about me and my experience
yeah and who wants to talk to somebody
who's not going to listen to who's not
going to believe what they're saying but
instead just try to put them in a box
and
like mine their true motives like
assuming that you're lying to me I'm my
goal in this conversation is to find the
real truth
that's what I'm going to do here today
right
just kidding no I know how that feels
yeah yeah I mean we we felt a lot of
that right and I think it's I think it's
the perfect start to the album
so before I move to the next song I want
to I want to thank uh Casey Frank you're
gonna thank people every time who play
well as we get new instruments okay
instrumentals all right fine Casey Frank
play that organ that's a real organ like
we had a fake organ in there originally
and then I and I was like man you know
me I'm not a details guy
it's like but Derek's like you know we
got to get a real organ and I'm glad he
did there's no fake instruments in any
of this stuff
uh that was recorded by tally Sherwood
at tritone recording and then the uh
okay the music video the lyric video
slash music video again that was done by
Jax Anderson uh
who she makes Incredible music on her
own and does incredible directing and so
shout out to Jax Anderson buddy system
season one theme song yes that's right
yeah
um okay for the second song this may be
a surprise to you this is actually
responding to some input that I got from
you but also as I
really started thinking about what there
was a point in which I thought I was
gonna do the first three singles were
gonna be the first three songs on the
album but then as I
I started think there's multiple things
going into this
because you're like who am I thinking
about when I am thinking about the
listener am I thinking about somebody
who's like who's it I like country music
who's this new kid on the block or I'm a
fan of Rhett and Link
and I don't even like country music but
what's Rhett got to say here
I couldn't decide who I was making that
thing for so I just stuck with
themes and it just ended up being that
we're still a very in like classic
country on the second song I went with
flash of rationality okay as a second
song and we could talk about it after we
listen to it all right I'm ready
foreign
[Music]
have a flash of
rationality but most times I do just
what I'm gonna do
it's easy for me to see what I already
see ain't got time for
inconvenient truths
I'm just a man I ain't no machine I do
the math the way it suits me don't get
me wrong you're making some sense but I
think I'll go before I am conveyed
sometimes I start
I love that one I mean it goes
even more country like it's probably the
most right right down the middle but
it's I mean it's got this very vintage
country Vibe yeah you know when you've
got a Charlie Crockett type well when
you retro something in your mind it's
one of those things where like what I
was that's my homage to Merle
you know that's why there's a trumpet in
there that's my homage to my favorite
era and your favorite era of Merle late
70s early 80s when he was like bringing
in jazz yeah and of course once ice put
my spin on it it's gonna be it ends up
in a different place so you might have
to be told that that's the reference but
the reason I did I put that song There
Is again I want to be like hey we're
still this is a country album
um it's the shortest song on the album
it's under three minutes it's the only
one that's under three minutes and so I
kind of want to be like all right from a
streaming perspective it's like I'm into
this album I get through that second
song but from a thematic standpoint it's
kind of saying listen first song I told
you
you don't have to agree with me and in
the second song I'm telling you I also
don't know what I'm talking about you
know what I'm saying yeah like I'm like
this I'm not I don't think I got
something incredible to say I don't
think I've got some incredible insights
into this I think that I'm smarter than
I actually am I buy a lot of books I
don't finish reading them
sometimes I think straight about this
stuff A lot of times I don't I'm just
being honest with you this isn't some
Treatise that you're supposed to like be
aligned with what's going on here I'm
just guessing the same way that you are
you know is kind of the Thematic message
and that's why I wanted it to be at this
point and that trumpet yeah it's like I
mean it is a surprise first time you
hear it like I mean I heard it a lot
later in the album before it was like
maybe four from the end when I heard it
and I was like oh you gotta you gotta
move this up especially with the when
that trumpet came in it's like oh you
give people this
surprise well I've got a funny story
about the trumpet so I knew from the
beginning that I wanted a trumpet
and the way that I indicated that I want
to trump it is when I sent Derek the
demo which is just me playing a guitar
and singing
I just got to that part of the song and
I just did a mouth trumpet yeah as you
would I guess and uh nothing like a good
mouth trumpet and he told me he was like
hey it's trumpet players it's tough he's
like we can get guitarists all day
but trumpet brass players
they're harder to get they're more
expensive whatever and I was like really
okay and you knew you wanted trumpet not
sax because I mean Merle he he traveled
with a sax player not a trumpet player
but he had it he had some and like he
had some trumpet solos more like the
Spanish
you know influence songs actually I was
hearing trumpet more than I was hearing
sex like you know like muffled like yeah
yeah yeah definitely
and makes sense so then we we actually
talked to I talked to Ward our friend
Ward Roberts yeah uh who you know he's
he's actually pretty connected in the
music world and his dad's like a jazz
player so I was like warbone we can't
find any and he was like I I know and he
sends me like a list and Chris Batista
was the first person that we contacted
and he was down to do the project and he
was like what do you want me to play
I said well
I've already done a mouth trumpet
of the Melody and I was like you can
play that and then play some other stuff
and then at the end of the day
we just all liked just him doing exactly
what I did with the mouse trap so you
got him to play a mouth trumpet that
sounded like a real trumpet to me I'm
gonna play you the demo this is the only
demo I'm gonna play because I want you
to hear the final songs and I don't want
to be here forever but I thought this
was funny enough you don't want to be
here forever uh what do you got to be to
put to play you the uh
all right and you can also see I'll play
a little bit of the song to see just how
what I do ain't as good as what we do
collectively once it gets in the hands
of a producer I know just enough about
enough stuff tonight when you bring
something up talking out of my ass is my
Mo I'm trying to learn to say I don't
know
[Music]
yeah he did better than you man
his mouth that sound awesome
and then he put he added the little
yeah yeah a little ending
yeah okay
that's flash of rationality I mean the
melody was intact though it's like you
know he played the same thing I'm
talking about your your singing Melody
oh yeah that one and this is the second
to last song written by the way the
flash of rationality
um okay because I wanted that theme of
like I started realizing that as you get
into the album
I'm I'm flirting with the whole thing is
flirting with self-importance and self
you know Indulgence but
I just wanted to remind you that hey
I don't think I'm some smart ass
I am I am a smart ass I'm more of a
smart ass than a smart guy so just
wanted to remind you
um yeah I appreciate you moving it to a
disclaimer placement in your album
instead of burying it yeah right and and
also the fact that I it's one of my
favorite songs on the album yeah it's a
good vibe yeah so you can walk you can
walk down the street to it
yeah you can walk back the other way
down the street to it third song is the
third single uh that just came out a
week before the album dropped give a
damn okay yes uh so I put this one early
in the mix as well and it's pretty big
departure let's listen
[Music]
guys who live well before your time we
make you think what you think God thinks
about wine
kind of thing will draw you in you are
like me why live for the here and now
when you've got to turn a TV they say
alive
that's not worth living but I'm pretty
sure I've braid my beard with all these
bugs I've given
I can't help but give a damn but damn
sometimes I wish I didn't the first time
I heard of the great beyond I was surely
spent I could be one of the Chosen Few
beyond the front lines I got something
in my pocket that'll give sight to the
blinds
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a good one man uh yeah I had
already heard believe me a lot earlier I
heard the first two singles so by the
time I listened to the album this is the
one that was like
Let's see we were on a plane
we were getting on a plane you were
listening to the album we were in the
airport yeah it was one of those things
where I had to
um I had to leave my phone off airport
mode airplane mode even though we were
taking off because I hadn't I was trying
to get the last song finished and then
I'm like man what's gonna happen all
right somebody gonna come up to me and
like kick me off this plane yeah they
throw you right out the door I just had
to I you know I had to get started to
finish but then my first you know I
leaned over to you you happened to be
there it was such a such a coincidence
and I was like that was the give a damn
now I was like give a damn oh that's the
one right there that's my I mean I
listen to it again here I'll tell you
what's my favorite but that was like the
first one I wanted to talk about
um
so let's talk about it I mean the guitar
hook right off the bat
do mouth guitar for that [ __ ]
was that my my thing was that what my
guess is that was part of the solo and
then
he you retroactively moved the second
half of solo to be the intro but uh am I
getting two in the weeds here well
actually I don't know exactly I don't
know what that process was exactly
because you know obviously when I see
this is the one demo that when I sent it
over I added a i yeah you know I record
in logic and then Derek is a Pro Tools
guy but I did a beat I was like this is
this is a rock song this is a this is
like this is like
in my mind like an Avett Brothers rock
song
now but they don't do lead guitar in the
same way
but that's what I was hearing usually
and so
uh he's got that banjo okay I dropped a
b in there so that to really so I could
play with the groove and it gives me the
energy that I need to sing the demo it's
the only song that I did that on okay
and then and I was just like listen I
want there's a couple of songs I was
like I want Alex to let loose on this
because if we need we need something
powerful and hooky on this and uh you
know typically Derek would send me
something and give me a couple of
options this he sent over and I was like
that's it that's what that that's that
hook that it needed oh yeah and it's
very I mean it's interesting that you
said it was Rock because it didn't it
did not turn out that way I mean it it's
it's quite a jaunt to use the word that
you used in the first song
folk rock yeah okay favorite Brothers if
you like go to the wiki he doesn't say
they're a country band it doesn't say
they're a bluegrass band it says they're
a folk rock band but the you know then I
think this is a folk rock the specific
like the chicken picking of that intro
it was that actually that was very uh
Merle to me but I'm talking more 60s
which I I liked I don't know if you even
felt like that was a connection to me
but it was like working man's Blues I
hear that I also hear
a hint of Leonard Skinner like yeah
but I mean you could hear Jackson Browne
yeah too so I would you know like you
know
but yeah I'm just saying it's
interesting how to take a little Skinner
I mean when you add that banjo and then
you add a bunch of [ __ ] given I mean
this is the explicit lyric song is it
does it have is it going to have an e on
when I when I oh yeah you're playing the
Mumford and son's card when I uploaded
there's some explicit track on this this
Mumford and songs album
used to no it doesn't it doesn't mean as
much as it used to and also I've noticed
that like certain artists in this genre
who like if Father John Misty has says
the f word in a song he doesn't put
explicit lyrics on it interesting I was
like well I'm gonna do it okay I'm gonna
do it
um one last thing about the production
the gang vocals like I just yeah it just
felt like it was it was such a relief
when that showed up when it it just felt
like Yeah because it just I was like oh
that's where this needed to go
you know in a good way yeah and that's
just me and Derek standing in the in his
Studio 12 feet from the mic just repeat
it just me and you have done gang vocals
100 times I mean do multiple voices and
stuff did you do any Muppet voices I
said I'm not gonna do the high voice
because that makes it sound like the
Muppets I was like that's one thing that
I've learned from me and Lincoln yeah it
was more
um you know Friends in Low Places
you bar sing along yeah it's definitely
it definitely that sealed the deal for
me between the guitar at the opening and
then the gang vocals at the end but this
song I mean
it's about evangelism right yeah because
you talk about you can be an evangelist
of anything
it's just that we're very steeped in a
church that had the label because it was
such so key to to our and as I've talked
about a lot of times my personality is
Evangelistic I like to persuade people
uh and I don't necessarily like that
about myself and this is a song about
man I can't help but give a damn but
sometimes I wish I didn't you know it's
it's it doesn't make your life easier
when you like to change people's minds
when you first heard about the great
beyond
and also yes smitten I think there's
something about people who feel like
there's got to be some purpose they're
naturally drawn to religion and they're
really when they when they're involved
in a religion to really go for it like I
became a missionary
because I thought that this is the most
important thing in the world like this
is so much more important than every
other Earthly thing that how do I go all
in
well you because you'd do it full time
and so that's why I became a missionary
and so and then what okay go ahead I
have another question and then so what
um yeah but then when you're you switch
teams you become an evangelist for that
team well when you in this the second
time you say it is not the great beyond
it's the first time I saw someone
someone's eyes light up so
is that like catching the bug of of
converting somebody yeah yeah like if I
can sit down and talk to you like if
you're if you're a Conservative
Christian you're not gonna have a
conversation with you and make you
question some fundamental things and it
seems like a light bulb goes off
um there's something you know incredibly
rewarding about that it's the same part
of your brain that lights up when you're
evangelizing someone and they come to
Christ you think that you're doing it
and you might be doing it out of love
and and belief that this person's soul
is being saved but it's an incredibly
personally rewarding if you were to scan
somebody's brain who was having was
doing evangelism and someone was
converting the serotonin
you know would be or whatever the brain
chemical is
you would be getting that reward you
would be getting the the reward that you
get
from you know winning in a game dopamine
you know there's a dopamine Rush Okay so
and and that is in my personality it's a
dopamine molecule so when I go to the
other team I and again the the the music
video for this is out the music video
for this is currently not been finished
being made it's an animated music video
from uh telling the future from Micah
abuzon who is this incredible animator
who made the music video
and this is you know the song is a
departure musically
and so the visual is is very much a
departure and it's kind of symbolizing
this in sort of uh as an analogy in a
different world kind of thing but the
whole point just being that
again the reason this is the third song
is multi-purpose number one it's like
hey this is another place that we're
going on this album it's not just
country we're getting into some
different stuff that is broadly country
but this Americana folk rock whatever
you want to call it
but thematically it's like hey I just
told you that I'm not don't take me
seriously uh
because I'm not taking myself as
seriously as I might seem sometimes but
also hey I don't even like the fact that
I want to change your mind I don't even
like that about myself it's making me
age more quickly
um but I'm just you know I'm processing
it through music you're the gray in your
beard is started under the ears almost
and in the middle and now in the middle
yeah and that's you know
there's multiple reasons for that so
this section of the album three songs
okay where now that I've sort of
thematically sort of tried to position
myself a little bit as like this is how
I want you to kind of take what's about
to come out before I start preaching at
you because I am going to preach at you
before the end of the album now I'm
directing my process towards people I
love starting with my parents then going
to my wife and then going to my kids
because spiritual deconstruction which
is an overused term but you know what
I'm talking about basically moving away
from traditional belief sort of
reorganizing the way you think about
this reorienting yourself
and in my case deconverting it's very
complicated for the people that you love
especially if they are still in that
Faith right
and so this is a song that was written
as I process the way that I feel towards
my parents and my parents feel towards
me
it's called sorry
[Music]
to
disappoint you approval
sword of my thing
took your book and made it mine never
colored outside the light and made my
own peace with the King
but then the integrity
beautiful
side me
started to
burn a hole in my heart
[Music]
I grabbed on that scarf
and pulled to there was nothing left
my whole world
fell apart
[Music]
and I did
nothing wrong
[Music]
so why do I feel like I need to say
sorry in a song
[Music]
what's the answer why do you feel like
you need to say sorry in a song
I don't know I don't have the answer
I think this is something that
anybody in this a similar situation like
you love and respect your parents you
grew you you uh you were a good kid
you know that this is a disappointment
to them in spite of
how well your life has gone or how well
things are with your family and your
career and all this stuff
if you disagree on this fundamental
thing
it's a disappointment you know I think
about my kids and I tried to explain
this to Locke to kind of get him to
understand the dynamic here
even though my parents really really
love me
um because I have
deconverted and publicly deconverted
it's kind of a double whammy not only am
I no longer a Christian but I'm this
public figure who talks about it
um you know the world that we come from
and you know how those kids are seen
right you know how people see me
and that impacts them
and the thing that I've I'm trying to
say in this song as well is that like
well to finish that thought I was like
lock if you know we've kind of raised
you according to a certain worldview
it's a much
more permeable world view than the one
that I was given
uh I'm not telling you exactly what to
think but there are certain values and
there are certain things that we hold
you know leading with love and and being
kind of the main value and I was like if
you were to like go off and become some
guy who was like
contrary to this you know
uh in some way there's multiple ways
that you could do that like that would
be difficult for me but multiply that
times 10 when I was become worried about
your eternal
destiny
that's what my parents live with and
that's what the parents of many people
who've deconstructed the converted lift
with
thankfully we still have a great
relationship and we're we are we love
each other and love trumps
everything else right the love is
stronger than the faith
which that's what Jesus himself said
right faith hope and love the greatest
of these is love because if you lose the
love you've lost the plot
um
so
but I mean that doesn't I feel bad like
the idea of my mom crying about me
yeah in my eternal destiny that hurts
yeah it hurts you because it hurts her
yeah you know it you know you you broke
their hearts yeah and you didn't do
anything wrong but you certainly don't
you know
the sign up sheet to break your parents
Hearts is not something that people are
lining up for
and you know especially with the type of
relationship that you have
you not only had but have with them but
like
yeah so you're able to say you did
nothing wrong for you to say they've
done you know you've done they've done
nothing wrong either the reason I say
they've done nothing wrong is because
again I know what it's like to be an
Evangelical Christian
and when your kids depart
not only do you like it's built into
that community that you become
responsible for it the Bible the Bible
basically implies that in a couple of
places that like your kids outcome I
mean it's it's a gray area for sure
there's ways to interpret and get around
it but like
regardless of what the Bible says the
Evangelical Community blames parents for
what their kids end up doing and so
right uh
that's that's a feeling it's like you
didn't do anything wrong like that's
when I talk about the fact that that's
why I did that Instagram post like you
guys taught me the gospel I understand
what the gospel means I understand Grace
by faith I'm not I'm not legalistic you
guys were never legalistic that's not I
didn't miss it the boat in that way I
mean it's yeah it kind of didn't do
anything wrong and it's not
parents get a bad rap across the board
you know it's like why is so and so
guilty of this crime or now in prison
it's like well how did how did their
their parents fail them you know and
I'll go a step further and say not only
did they not do anything wrong they did
a lot of things right and this is a very
difficult thing that I'm saying in this
song that I can't you know I haven't the
Integrity that they gave you turned
burned a hole in your my parents
concerned with truth
especially my dad because he thinks a
lot like me My dad became a Christian in
his early 30s so a late a later life
conversion right so it was a very strong
conversion that was immediately like
impacted him in so many different ways
and my mom as well they both became
Christians at the same time
and his concern his lifelong concern
with truth and putting truth above
everything else my personality is
exactly the same way and the thing that
I want to be able to say is that hey the
same thing that got you to suddenly wake
up in your early 30s and realize that
life has got to be about more than just
going through the motions like there's
got to be more to this life and that led
you to making a profession of faith in
Christ that was truly life-changing I
believe
that same instinct is what brought me to
the conclusions that I came to
so it's actually what you did right
ironically to make me really concerned
about truth and like hey if this is the
most important thing I want to
understand is it really true and I came
to my conclusion that I am at right now
I always leave room I say right now
because I leave a lot of things open is
that it's not true fundamentally it's
not true Christianity is not true if I
thought that it was true I would still
be a part of it I don't think that it's
true I think that there's a lot of
things about it that you can't know
and so
but what I'm saying is like even though
I I'm made a lot of these decisions
because of the good things that you
passed along I know it's still deeply
disappoints you and I'm sorry about that
so the the part of like why do I
feel like I need to say I'm sorry like
yeah
I think that I know that resonates that
totally makes sense and then but let's
talk about the inner song Part why do I
feel like I need to say I'm sorry in a
song you know there's are there certain
things that
you're saying in this song that you
couldn't say
to their face like I think that applies
to the conversation song and many other
ones it's just not I don't talk this way
to the two people directly you know even
the next couple songs we'll listen to
it's the same thing it's like I can say
it a lot better in a song than I can
just sitting down and saying it to you
specifically with my parents It's
Complicated by the fact that it's so
emotional yeah
um and I can't have a real conversation
about this you know
without especially my mom like she's
heartbroken right so it's
we just don't talk about this stuff
directly we talk about the things that
you know moms and sons talk about about
life and what are the kids doing and
that kind of thing and maybe we will get
where we can talk more directly about
this stuff but it's too hurtful
yeah because it's I mean there's
I mean you say in the song that like
neither we're probably not going to
change each other's minds yeah right
yeah so then you're left with
just just kind of
it becomes this emotional thing
that you know it still may be really raw
yeah yeah
um so
what
did you feel afraid to even to put the
song out there or did you or is this
like what do you are their hopes
attached to it in terms of how you can
process it in that relationship or is
that
none of none of none of the listeners
business yeah I would say that I don't I
don't know I don't know yeah you know I
think I'm a lot of these songs are just
as much for you know I'm the reason I
didn't just write this song and send it
to my parents and I made it a public
thing is because
um
I think this will resonate you know I
this is this is this is happening this
is like this is a worldwide
cultural movement of people moving out
of these types of belief systems
that their parents hold very sacred and
it's difficult
and there's no solution in this other
than like hey I'm just identifying with
the emotion that this
stirs in people
I think it's
absolutely beautiful song in the way
that it it resonates outs even beyond
the context of like changing your
religious beliefs you know there's and I
think we've talked about this before
it's just you know you your relationship
with your parent parents Guardians like
the people who you know people who are
older than you as you grow up and you
become an adult yourself it's like the
nature of our relationships change
and sometimes if they don't that's
that's weirder than if they do but the
changes that you go through
in that you know people who love who
love you and we're there for you your
whole life can't they're making
different decisions they're Landing in a
different place
that's a it's a scary thing to to
navigate a relationship where you have a
fundamental disagreement you know you
talk about issues of identity you know
that
whether it could still be religious it
could be
um you know relational sexual whatever
the case may be there's so much that you
have to navigate it's just I I think it
it's your story
and I think that it will resonate with
other people's stories in a way that it
just kind of it it sprouts wings and
that's why I think this is a beautiful
song
even if you're just doing
um the the spiritual exploration I think
it's a great album but this is a
standout because
it's so relatable sadly to so many
people and the irony is is that yeah
it's
you don't have a lot of the baggage like
from your parents I mean we all have
baggage but like you you but it's a lot
worse for a lot of people you have an
active
relationship where like you know you
still want to spend time together at
holidays and like you care about each
other and it's not it's a law has not
been built up you still have a
relationship yeah and that's a and that
and just you know listen I give them a
lot of credit for that
yeah
because in the system that they're in it
would not be
there there are certain biblical
passages that you could decide you were
going to follow that would mean you
would cut off a relationship just to be
honest with you
um and they're choosing love
yeah and but that doesn't mean that this
wasn't deeply
uh emotional and uh
difficult for you man for them it's like
kind of you know it's under a best case
scenario that it happened and it and
you're still illustrating the depth with
which like there's parts that you you
can all Express in certain ways and like
you're not
you're not able to get into it still
it's like
I just think about the people who's like
everything else you know he
to add on to it so yeah I think it's a
big one man
and I wanted to put it there because you
know it's that's one of my favorite
songs on the album
um I just love the way that one came
together uh and to kind of start that
section
then of course the next song is the
second single which is me writing a song
to my wife it's called where we're going
[Music]
oh
I picked up on it first thing
you weren't like the ones I'd known
might have been from the same place
coming from somewhere all your own a few
hours on a wooden bench that's all it
took to do me and you knew then had to
make it quick before I made us fall into
sin so I don't know where we're going
but I know I want you to go with me
don't care much about the destination
as long as you're there that's where I
wanna be
took a different tone
started too
you know it's amazing
for a song
that is so sweet
to be about
going through so much difficulty you
know
uh it because it is I mean especially
when you throw that like classic country
and I don't mean in terms of time I mean
just like just the way that you know the
sweetness of a sweet country song
especially when you go to that
that bridge at the end or whatever you
call it where it's like now I'm gonna
put this all in perspective it's like
you thought you followed this template
which is like I'm telling you a story
about a relationship you can see the
music video in your head typically it
would the country music singer would be
singing you see the couple and it
wouldn't be them but you did the right
thing you put yourself and Jesse in the
in the video right yeah so that was if
you didn't know that was Jesse singing
uh yeah and uh Ben Eck here who's been
mythical for
almost a decade
you know I I wanted this the whole thing
to be outside of mythical but
he was so excited when he heard about
the project he was like hey whatever I
could do to help I just want to be a
part of it and so we collaborated on the
video and he he brought it to life but
yeah getting Jesse to sing again I I
wrote this song
for her for Valentine's Day two years
ago or 2021
and uh
so then that was back before this album
it was a there was a thing it was before
I even knew that I was making an album
really
and that it was or that was it was a
country album right so this song wasn't
even conceptualized as a country song
the first time I wrote it
you couldn't help yourself though it was
yeah I remember you talked yeah you
talked about singing this song to her on
this on the podcast yes you alluded to
that so yeah it kind of pre this is the
first song you wrote for the album you
didn't even know it well it's not the
first song I wrote uh because I was just
writing songs what's the first as a
process the first song I wrote is the
last song on the album and actually had
this maybe this may be the second song
that I that I wrote okay uh but again
there was a number of songs there in in
the middle that were I didn't know I was
making an album I'm just writing writing
music and like recording demos but
you're I mean
we've talked about it a lot when we talk
about the deconstruction
in the deconstruction episodes but I
mean
it just it brings it into sharp Focus
how when your your relationship is built
so strongly on the rock of Christ right
that whenever you decide to move your
home base somewhere else
uh it that that is a scary Prospect and
if you don't make that move together and
again
we didn't make the move at the same time
uh you know I kind of moved first
and then Jesse was you know obviously
scared resistant crying that's what I
talk about in the song it's just like
when I started having these like this is
what I'm thinking
I really didn't want to tell you about
this because I know how much it'll upset
you she would just cry you know it was
tough it's one of the reasons it was
such a long and lengthy process
but
we eventually got to where we're not in
exactly the same place spiritually but
we're it isn't like she wants me to be
anywhere or I want her to be anywhere we
both are like we're untethered from
Orthodoxy frankly and um
and
but there's so many couples where that's
not the case
you're in very different places
fundamentally and not only is that just
intrinsically difficult but you've been
told if you're from a conservative
Evangel back Evangelical background
that you cannot be unequally yoked that
it doesn't work and you're also told
that everything that you have in life
every good Instinct that you have
comes from God comes from the spirit of
God and everything bad comes from you
uh again this is I'm not speaking for
all the evangelicals but this is sort of
the perspective that I had
all your good instincts are from God all
your bad instincts are from you
and what that means is that the moment
that you begin thinking that this God
thing may not make sense in the same way
you're just naturally programmed to
think that only bad is now left and now
what are we going to base this marriage
on
love
I thought we had to base it on Jesus so
so
this is an example of some of the things
we are warned about turned out to be
pretty good
you know there there was a lot of
trepidation like I definitely relate
with me and Christy and our spiritual
Journeys like the trepidation of
everything that you realize you believed
if it wasn't I mean it was overtly
taught in a lot of ways like you're
talking about the unequally yoked thing
but and just how it permeates
yeah every everything you you don't even
know you believe uh is you know it you
can feel it as fear before you can state
it logically and when you're in a
deconstruction process it's like yeah
you're in this you're in this state of
fear a lot of times and you can't
articulate it
and but to get through that with
anything that you get through as as a
couple and you if if you do come out
stronger on the other side then you can
say oh wow there's part this is maybe it
was worth it you know right can't you
say that
I think that
um
when you strip away
the ideology
that was holding you together
and it really becomes about
just love
in this commitment
and I'm not again
I know I give a lot of these disclaimers
I'm not saying that people who are
Christians
who are in a relationship that it is all
about like it isn't about love
it's just about their ideology the thing
I would say that I would challenge
Christians on is I actually think that
you know a lot of guys in Christian
circles this is what you hear
they're like man if I didn't if I wasn't
a Christian I'd be cheating on my wife
this is a very common sentiment
and I'm like dude that's some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] man like think about what you just
said
yeah think about what you just said
what if the reason you don't cheat on
your wife is because you love her
yeah like how about how about and here's
what I would say I think the reason
because here's the deal
infidelity happens a whole lot with
inside and outside of the church it
seems like that commitment actually
doesn't play much of a role and so if
you are faithful I think it actually
means that you're faithful you don't
have to constantly give credit to some
external source for every good thing you
do maybe you're faithful because you
have the ability to be faithful in
yourself
and
you know so so that is an example of
like oh this relationship that is and I
listen I'm not perfect Jessie's not
perfect I'm not saying that it's always
going to be great it has continually
gotten better over the years for us as
we've grown together
but who knows what what challenges we'll
meet you know
but when the rubber meets the road I
want to our relationship to be based on
mutual love and respect and a commitment
that is independent of our worldview and
ideology
and
you know and I think that that's
actually the case in most relationships
even the ones where the ideology is
ideology is present what do you mean by
more than a savior we needed help
because it's you know I think from the
I don't know that that's more of a head
scratcher
um what I meant by that is
in the in the Evangelical circles that
we ran around in
um
you get a lot of help from a spiritual
perspective right like and even when you
go to therapy or you go to couples
counseling it's always run through this
very specific biblical grid
uh and it's just like if your
relationship with Christ is intact and
flourishing then everything else in your
life will be okay
is kind of the implication right
and I think there are sometimes when
you just need help you just actually
need somebody to
help you navigate your relationship
navigate your own emotional and mental
well-being
you know
I I it's funny because I I know
Christians who
uh
prefer for their therapist to not be a
Christian because they don't want it run
through this biblical grid which a lot
of times is more hurtful than helpful so
I think that the point there is that
like hey it isn't just about getting
saved and having this savior the saving
knowledge of Christ it's like no like
couples need help they just don't need
to be right with God
they need to figure this they need to
figure out how to navigate a
relationship
um
and I think what we needed each
individually in our in our own
circumstances in in situations but also
as a couple like we needed to work on us
apart from just getting our world view
straightened out like that isn't that's
not it's just not the case it's just not
true that if you get the right belief
you know so much of conservative
Evangelical Christianity is about
believing the right things you go to
church on Sunday and what do they talk
about well hold on now we're not to the
preachies preach these songs yet you're
getting there uh so and that's our
experience is that hey when we actually
started thinking about our relationship
and thinking about each other rather
than God
things got better
what's next
this is the third and this three song
section to people I love and this is the
song that I wrote for my boys okay
buckle up
it's called creaking back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
forgotten
dance
according to a plan
then the blue Bridge
still the light that I want for you
still alive that I think is true
it's just now the path day
quiet so spray
a secret I probably should not tell is
that I still feel like a kid myself
been in over my head since we brought
you home
biggest thing that I've learned is what
I don't know but I'm your dad
I know that
and I love you to the creek and back
another tearjerker come on now
this so those three together you just
want everybody to cry
yeah but now yeah it's got Wings man
like I said in just like I was talking
about before
you know any any parents gonna say oh
God I know exactly I know exactly what
that feels like to just should I say
that I am I'm clueless
I'm just as clueless as you but in a
different way you know
um it's it's extremely powerful to to
put that out there I know it's going to
resonate with people and the piano
doesn't hurt
yeah I wanted to do I wanted to you know
do a piano song and it's not me playing
the piano I know that I learned how to
play the piano for the for a tour we did
but that's a real piano player uh Eden
Dover
um and
of course I you know I wrote it on
guitar but I was I I was hearing it as
as piano and then and also it's kind of
interesting because
this is the kind of music that like it's
a little more
you know it's piano based so you're kind
of getting into you know it's not like a
Billy Joel or a uh you know an Elton
John song but it's the most like that of
anything on the album which is kind of
like music that we've connected I've
connected with the boys over
um but yeah exactly this is just I had
written those two songs to you know it's
on to my parents onto my wife and I was
like
you know I think that when you have a
fundamental shift in world view
like again
held you up before God and man the first
this is that's the dedication which
incidentally is a piece of video in the
in the in the home video footage in the
where we're going music video oh wow is
meet us up there in front of the church
with lock yeah
and so which is a ceremony
arguably just as much if not more about
the parents than it is about it's
basically saying you get up in front of
you get up in front of everybody and you
say I promise to raise this kid
you respond to a series of questions I'm
raising this kid
uh you know
according to the gospel and to raise
them to serve Jesus and to make a
decision yeah uh I mean in my church my
my kids were actually baptized and there
was an added thing well I didn't save
them link that if they
you know that clinging to This Promise
that's open to interpretation that's
like okay they are already saved as long
as every everybody does their job well
you're kind of claiming them for Christ
you know
um
to me this song is more powerful
knowing at what stage of fatherhood you
wrote it because I I think there's a lot
of artists that will
have a child and then of course they're
going to start writing songs about their
baby there's there's so many songs like
an endless playlist of this artist that
you know had their first baby and then
they had to write a song Sturgill's
whole album uh sailor's Guide to the
universe or whatever it is it's like
it's all based on him having a kid I
mean uh is Childish Gambino I mean it
but it's you're looking at this baby and
you're like
ever since the day I brought you home
I've been scared shitless you know so
for you to say that and you know lock is
off at College thank God and and
Shepherd's not too not as far behind as
it seems like you know so meaning that
it it happened I don't mean I'm thankful
he's gone I'm saying that like he got
there so my you see my point right I
mean it's it's it's strangely
comforting as a parent to hear this
knowing that you're you've got you've
got kids that are that are on the cusp
of adulthood well I think it goes back
to what we've talked about as we as we
talk about relating to our kids that
it's much less about the things that you
say and much more about the things that
you do and
you know
I think modeling
cluelessness
to my children
that's a harsh way to put it but
modeling humility or whatever however
you want to say it like hey man
everything that we've done
has been motivated by love but it's all
guesswork and it's the best guess that
we have at the time
and I know for a fact that you're going
to be processing the mistakes that I've
made
forever
do you know what I mean
yeah
hopefully because this I mean the song
is for them first right hopefully just
hearing that
is helpful to them
I'm so glad you don't end up with a
bunch of resentment you know a parent
who can't admit
that they made a bunch of mistakes
that is much more trauma-inducing than
the mistakes sometimes
yeah I mean it definitely piles it on
I'm glad that you didn't
go like cute country and then change CR
I love you to the creek and back to in
the final chorus saying I love you with
my creaking back
like I'm so old
my back sounds like a door
that would have been it's not too late
mistake it's not too late
it is too loud where are we going now
well where we're going is that was the
song I wrote to Jesse
you said where are we going oh
what song is next well I do I do before
we move on I want to say so obviously
that was Jesse singing along with that
song as well so Jesse sings on three
songs she's the mother of those children
and so she did an amazing job there and
uh thanks to there's you know we wanted
to do that cello and the violin the
strings were like a last minute Edition
because we had just an electric base in
there that Derek had played
and I was like I'm hearing something
else and then I heard a song I was
listening to some song and it was piano
and cello I was like that's what we need
so we got Dave Egger to play cello and
Lisa fayco to play violin so thank you
for that making that song what it is now
we're getting back into uh This song is
called only thing uh and this is again
sort of back to the processing because
I'm about to move into a place where I'm
not really singing to individuals but
I'm more kind of in my own head and then
finally directing some things out to the
church got a couple of songs that are
directed at the church towards the end
but this is back to like processing okay
only thing
[Music]
I could argue with the best of them
about where we came from
Advance you over coffee that Jesus was
God's Sons
that empty feeling that
everybody feels
use it against
[Music]
you I was sure I sure can be
I was working for eternity
there was hell to pain
if you saw it another way now the only
thing I'm certain of is that I
answered about much
it's easy to be right it's not so easy
to choose love
sometimes I miss that feeling of having
it figured out
have to fight that temptation to know
what life's all about
[Music]
so it's sometimes it's
it's I don't think he said sometimes you
said it's easy
to be right
you said sometimes it's not easy to
choose love so you're talking about this
it's easy to be right it's not so easy
to to choose love so it's like
that's the
that's the struggle right that I mean
that's what you're speaking from
experience here
this one is just kind of that
I think that
it's very difficult when when you're a
Christian
um
and I would say when you adhere to any
particular religious philosophy and you
really adhere to it like you're pretty
sure that you're right about it right
like
being right about it is kind of
important
there's a lot at stake
um
specifically I mean
under you know believing the Creed
they're believing the right thing about
Jesus is is the ticket to heaven right I
mean ultimately when you break it down
you got to think and believe the right
you have to believe the right thing
and your Eternal Destiny depends on that
and I think that
it's difficult when you're in that
situation to Envision what it would be
like to just not be sure about that
that's one of the scariest things for me
as a when I was transitioning away from
Christianity which is like whoa like
this is so crazy
to like just accept the fact that you
don't have to know what you think about
this stuff that you can be uncertain
about this stuff
um
and it's really hard it's like that's
why it says uh and of course it's like
I'm trying to essentially I'm trying to
break the habit
of of knowing what life's all about
right that that's a that's a tendency to
like you got to know what life's all
about and you gotta believe it strongly
and you've got to share it
and you gotta and it's difficult to be
like no I can let go of that I don't
have to know what the ultimate purpose
of the universe is and I believe that
anyone who says that they've got it
figured out almost assuredly is wrong
like the one thing I know is if you say
you know what the secret of the universe
is and what the purpose of all this is
whatever your particular take on it
you're basically ruling that out from
being the truth because you've come up
you know you and some system of man has
come up with that from my perspective I
think when from my experience
When Love Takes a
close second like even if it's a razor
edge like
like a thin slice just below truth
it it's a problem it's a problem when
you start to relate to people when you
start to
try to empathize with people
you know it's
it's hard to love somebody when it's
there's a subservience to what you
believe to be an absolute truth
and it always felt weird and that's why
for so many years I would hide
like my my beliefs and my affiliation
with the Evangelical Church was because
I just couldn't stand by the implied
judgment that was the headline
it's like too many people I've I feared
would associate with me with with
judgment
and not love first yeah and I realized
that like I related to a lot of people
for some so much of my life
with love being subservient and people
can feel that they know it they know it
sticks out like a sore thumb oh yeah and
it's like
yeah I mean that that's that's one of
the big things that you know finally
kind of broke me out of that thinking
was like
just like it's not something to hide
it's something to break up away from
well you know interesting I've been
thinking about this exact concept a lot
lately
um you know the way I've kind of
right the way I understand it right now
is
if something about your particular
ideology or philosophy
makes you necessarily think that someone
is fundamentally different right so if
you if you're a Christian if you're an
Evangelical Christian and what I mean by
that is if you believe that the only way
to be in a right relationship with God
is through Jesus Christ
and so if you're not in a right
relationship with Jesus Christ you are
condemned you're not really a child of
God right you're going to spend eternity
in hell
if I believe that about you even if I
love you
I think less of you
by default I'm I think that I'm going to
spend eternity with God and I think that
you are not going to spend eternity with
God sure it may be because of Grace and
it may be because of the Gospel
I mean it doesn't make you a bad person
to believe that but the relational
Dynamic that that creates is that this
person who's on the receiving end of
that judgment is what it is it is a
judgment it is a it is a determination
you their relationship can only be so
deep with you so if you're a Christian
and you think that I'm going to hell
again you may be that is your that's
your theological opinion you can't help
yourself believe that what I'm saying is
that I can only have so deep of a
relationship with you
because there's a fundamental thing that
you believe about me that separates us
and ultimately results in me being
discarded and judged in a way that
you're not going to be and that's just a
difficult dynamic
that is a result of fundamentalist
belief about things
but the moment you say hey this is my
take but I'm not really that certain
about it and I'm not prepared to say
that you're condemned
the relational possibilities really open
up
that's a difficult thing to do though
it's a very difficult thing to do if you
if you hold to a particular theology
what do we head next so this is the
biggest departure this is the last song
that I wrote
uh and I wanted there to be what I would
call a badass country song
and uh I'll explain what it means and
why it's in this spot on the album after
we listen to it it's called kill a man
[Music]
today I'm gone
[Music]
I'm gonna squeeze his life out
my bed
[Music]
for way too long
only thing he does right is doing wrong
foreign
[Music]
you can just say it man
just just freaking say it
say it what
this was about me I'm gonna kill you
this is me letting you know that I'm not
gonna kill you this is this is the
badass blues guitar you got some Kenny
Wayne Shepherd in here
well they've got the load notes you got
to hide here's the thing
this song was never going to be a part
of the album I thought I was done with
10 songs then as we kept producing this
thing and Alex kept coming through and I
was like this dude's really talented oh
yeah he did awesome and I was like I
just feel like I've got to write a song
that lets him it's just like hey hey
buddy I'm taking off the leash I'm
taking off the leash and I just want you
to be a badass on the guitar and just do
what you can do
yeah and so thematically I mean the
the message is
and I don't want to let me just say I'm
not going to say exactly there's a
principle that was true in my former
philosophy as a Christian that is true
now
as a whatever I am hopeful agnostic
uh that I think is an important
principle in life
uh that I still abide by and this song
is a sort of an exploration of that
concept okay
I'll let you figure out exactly what
that is but uh and thanks to Jesse for
Lending her um operatic vocals yeah you
know she's done that for us before back
in the day this is you know Jesse
majored in in voice specifically
classical voice so we knew I knew I
wanted that middle section to be like
kind of a weird departure and there's
like some backtracked guitars and stuff
or whatever the term is for what reverse
what are the backing vocals that sound
like a chant say are they words
which part huh huh it's like a
percussive oh they just say yeah yeah
they say yeah yeah yeah okay all right
clever cleared that up yeah it's kind of
a it's a little bit of a
again I don't think there's this Jack
White song that sounds exactly like this
but you could imagine him having done
something like this sure you know and
and and that's Derek doing that
percussion he just did it like outside
of his studio in Burbank like on his
driveway with like sounds like you're
you're you've killed somebody and you're
dragging them you're dragging them to
the yeah well it's kind of like you've
got somebody and you've and you've uh
you've got him in shackles and you're
taking them
taking him to kill him you know oh
that's more kind of the you know you
could take it however you want to but
that was what I was thinking
uh now we get final three songs these
two that I just put together originally
I wanted them to be spread out and then
I was just like I've kind of set the
stage to
these are my two
songs directed at the church
okay first one is called in vain
[Music]
there's quite a few things
you don't seem to mind
I'm trying to figure out just where you
draw the line
was watching people die
seems to be fine
but God forbid a nipple over
Jesus Christ
I swore to understand
took me quite a bit
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
see I feel like there's going to be a
lot of people
Christians who are like hey I I agree
with all that man I agree with all that
I think it's it's difficult though in
practice I mean I'm just saying from
from personal experience to to go from
yes it's you know
Jesus teachings and the the by Biblical
teaching can be you know we want to just
boil it down to this actionable stuff
where we can check boxes I know for me I
wanted to be able to check boxes and say
I'm well within bounds I'm I I can feel
secure about my approach to life and
um with rules
and that's not how Jesus talked right
and so and I was taught enough of that
to know to try to counteract it but I
mean with my Tendencies it's you know I
tended to really when it when you boil
it down to rules and
even if frivolous ones like okay
don't say damn but definitely don't say
God damn and like uh don't say oh my God
you know it's like it just
it makes it easier to process but none
of this stuff is that easy to process it
should it shouldn't be
you know but as humans I think we we
at times you just fall back
on this reductionist approach well I
think it's you know I've always been
fascinated with how offensive
using God's name in vain
God damn saying God damn is so and this
is something I tell people from other
parts parts of the world and from other
parts of the United States I'm like if
you like if you get upset about
something you say Jesus Christ like that
is like oh like certain Evangelical
Christians it's like
it's like a poison man it is so
offensive to them
and I'm like it's so interesting to me
that that is the thing that is so
offensive but there's all this other
stuff
that is actually offensive that you
don't care about hey we I yeah I heard
it you listed them out nipples well I
remember nipples and I just you know
it's just it's always been fascinating
to me and I see this music video this is
the one I want it's just one nipple the
whole time so can it sing it's a singing
novel yeah like where the milk comes out
it can actually start singing yeah
that's yeah the nipple part
um
so I don't know I just I I wanted to say
because just like you're right I tell
you lots of Christians who would be like
I agree with this but were you gonna
play it for somebody because it says God
damn it a number of times
you know and again not all Christians
are like this a lot of Christians have
woken up to the fact that like hey guys
like cursing
and even saying like do you really think
that that's what that commandment was
about like you think the Commandment to
not use God's name in vain was about not
using God's name as a curse word like
you really think that's where that
commandment was ever about it's so
interesting that it's what it became
about
um
but you're totally right most reasonable
Christians of all Stripes will be like
yeah yeah I completely agree with this
like that's not what the gospel is about
it's not about all these other things
um
so yeah again I my my um
yeah I think this is I think ultimately
this is all pretty like soft stuff it's
not
you know that my the point of this album
was not I mean this condemned it's just
the Supreme Court case I mean that I
mean that's something that
we I mean I think it there's a couple
places where it oh it starts to happen
well and this song was written before
the the Roe v Wade
that was overturned
this in what even it wasn't in
anticipation of that particular case
even
there's always a Supreme Court case that
Christians think that God is on the side
of an issue and that that's what Jesus
would believe and that's probably the
best one is that they just fundamentally
believe Jesus would be pro-life no
questions asked and it's just like
really though like you really think that
show me the biblical evidence of that
yeah
um so anyway
uh I think this is again it's not like
I'm expect like if you're a Christian
and you're Conservative Christian and
you completely fundamentally disagree
with me and you've made it to this point
in the album it's like okay these these
songs may be challenging for you but
again this wasn't about hey this is a
message for the church first and
foremost I am it is
but it's more like
when you are deconstructing or
deconverting like there's a lot of
things that you're thinking and you're
beginning to see things you're like man
like this was the way that it always was
this is how we thought we were so
offended by this thing but yet all this
other stuff didn't offend us and that's
weird and and hypocritical and you just
see it
and you want to talk about it and you
want to say it you want to point out the
hypocrisy
um
but this next song
fruit
is even more specifically about what I
see as the hypocrisy in the church
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
makes me think we might be reading
different lives
[Music]
I can't quite square that with you AR-15
[Music]
tear let the little children come to me
you just watched as they were torn from
their families
I don't see the joy but I'm not sure I
got the patience to walk you anymore
I don't mean to be unkind and I'd like
to keep
just looking for the self-control to
agree to disagree
[Music]
this one hits hard man where's the love
I don't feel the love I mean it's if if
somebody honestly says that I mean you
just can't
it's undeniable you know if somebody
doesn't feel loved
you know it's what can you say to that
it's it's one thing for someone to say
yeah but I love you it's like
um you know I just think even on like in
an intimate relationship have you ever
been in a point where you're like
uh someone you love told you I don't I
don't feel the love it doesn't I don't
I'm not feeling that from you it's like
good luck coming up with a response you
know the damage is already done like the
writing's on the wall and you can you
can try to explain yourself at that
point and I feel like that's
that's this resonates with me so much
because it's it
it's
I don't know I just I just see it it's
it's frustrating and I don't wanna I
don't want to paint with a broad stroke
and say like yeah this is the problem
with the church
overall and like did you really put
words in my mouth I think that it's
you know you you give some examples in
there when you talk about AR-15 when you
talk you allude to immigration
um uh practices
um
um
yeah
what who's the red letter crowd like
Define that because I think at that
point you're talking about infighting
within the church I was like you're
talking about even I'm talking about my
perspective my my former self's
perspective on Progressive Christians
right
I used to be like
so red letter Christians is the thing
that there's people who identify with
the words of Jesus because there are
some versions of the Bible where all the
words of Jesus are in red and all the
rest of the words are just black right
and so there are people who say I'm a
red letter Christian
and what that means is that the thing
that I hold the most sacred and the
thing I really take seriously is the
words of Jesus and then everything else
is sort of open to interpretation or not
as important okay
um in thinking that way makes you uh you
know Jesus didn't condemn a whole lot
besides hypocrisy right he didn't go
around he he got condemned by the
religious zealots because he was hanging
out with the people he shouldn't hang
out with right and he didn't come with a
really judgmental tone he was like I'm
about building relationships I'm
bringing love into this situation
and so it's essentially a way of saying
hey I used to be like Progressive
Christians or whack because they're just
not comfortable with the whole truth
they're taking the truth that they're
comfortable with that kind of fits into
our cultural context and is culturally
acceptable and then they're kind of
minimizing or even rejecting the
difficult truths that our culture
actually needs to hear that are in the
Bible
and I was like you can't just say I want
this to be true and this is
uncomfortable so I'm not going to make
that I'm not going to believe that I
used to look down on them
and now I'm like those are the people
I'm rooting for within the church is the
ones who are saying yeah yeah I am
prioritizing love over judgment I'm
prioritizing love over faith even
believing the right thing
um
because it's not so much like you know
because you might say what you said
earlier when you were like when you say
I love you but
it's very difficult and a Christian
might say yeah but
I love you but I think that what you're
doing is sinful like I can't not say
that
if you know I have to tell you that I
think something you're doing is wrong I
don't think we're talking about that
situation
that can get complex
you know
I think what we're talking about is the
fact that as a whole
the Evangelical Church especially in
America has aligned itself
with like the darkest parts of our
nature as a country right like you
aligned yourself with Donald Trump I
mean I did a whole podcast about this
I don't care what the outcome was I
don't care if the Supreme Court case
went the way that you wanted it
you aligned yourself with someone who is
the least christ-like politician to ever
have been in power in the United States
of America
full stop not an exaggeration not
hyperbole you aligned yourself with the
least christ-like politician to ever
have been in power in the history of our
country
I don't feel the love the most reliable
indicator for support of Donald Trump in
this country is if you are a
conservative Evangelical Christian
that is the most reliable indicator
as long as that's true you guys have
lost the plot you've lost the love
full stop
that's what the song's about
well you said full stop I can't I can't
say anything else
you said full stop twice yeah full stop
said it three times well I mean we
didn't even talk about the fruit
Illusions they can get that themselves
fruit of the illusions
right yes fruit of the spirit
um there's only one more song all right
what it's called Old letters
and it is the first song that I wrote
of all these songs wrote it in 2019.
[Music]
I still remember when
we used to talk
you never said much but I knew what you
thought
you wrote it down for me
long ago
I read your letters to keep from feeling
along
there's not just one thing
I could point to
that began to push me
away from you
all I can say is that I change
it was just like you to stay the same
stay the same
so
the first song you wrote is the last one
on the album it makes sense to me that
the first song you wrote is a letter to
God unless I'm getting this really wrong
no link this is to you
uh all his letters to you this is your
letter to him
um as you're starting the journey it
seems like that's a good starting place
like if you were
when you told me this is what you wrote
first that's why it was it wasn't
written as the first of a set of songs
it was just like
oh I've never I never write I never
write about complex emotions oh we write
comedy songs you know I mean I this
might be the first serious song I've
ever written
well maybe like back in the day when we
were writing like Christian music
uh well yeah that's true yeah back in
high school but
um
yeah
it was very much just I'm processing
this thing that is this is kind of how I
think about god it feels like a it feels
like a breakup it feels like you you
think about the relationship that you
had
and you run things back to your mind and
like what was I how what was I actually
thinking what was going on but the
reason I you know this is the last song
on the album is you know I am committed
to being open like I I am I have not
closed my accounts with reality I've not
closed my accounts with God I don't I'm
not an atheist and the reason that I say
I'm not an atheist is because
I lean into the idea that there's
something else going on here you know I
don't know what that is I don't know
what the nature of that is I don't know
what the nature of God is I don't know
what the nature of the universe is but I
don't know what it is and so therefore
I'm not ready to conclude what it is and
it may be that I had got the first time
around
when I was in a relationship with God as
I would have described it I I had him
wrong
I had her wrong I had it wrong I had
them wrong whatever you want however you
want and who knows what the future holds
right if the last 20 years of my life
indicate anything is that the next 20
years could send me in a wildly
different direction
than I would have ever anticipated
and so the last thing I want to do is
close myself off to if if that God
out there in there around there
is wants to be in relationship and wants
to reveal some kind of truth to me I'm
not going to be the one to stand in the
way of that guy doing that and so I
leave it open and unresolved I enjoyed
the production technique of like the the
panned vocals but is there irony in the
fact that
your processing of God's letters
is like a conversation with yourself
well the so
there's a song There's Jason Isbell song
that I love uh chaos and clothes I think
is the name of it and uh he does this
technique of basically doubling his
voice in the stereo split of the two
voices
and I knew I wanted to do a song like
this and I thought that this song was a
perfect one to do it because it just
represents
the possibility to me it's not some I I
it is interesting that you take it that
way which I'll take that I'm not taking
credit for it but like is this just a
conversation with myself
this is why this is the only song on the
album where I did my own Harmony because
I was like this is so personal
that it's like there's so there's two
Melodies and there's two harmonies and
there's two guitars
and it's just like represents
the multiple perspectives and how where
we go from here is something that is
just kind of it's open the the
possibilities are open and I and I don't
know I'm not trying to go any particular
place
well I you know I
I celebrate the fact that this thing
exists is out there it's a complete
project I mean I know with everything
that
you've been through and how the pandemic
in a lot of ways gave you the space to
make this possible there's still a lot
of stuff that's going on and more every
day it's like it's nice that you you
follow through on this vision and this
is out there and it's um you know it's
it's it'll outlive you
you mean they're still gonna be on the
internet after I'm dead oh yeah that's
great I mean that you
as a as a project I think it's it's
important and I I celebrate it well
thanks thanks for that and thanks for
listening to it with me
um you know I think that the
the most rewarding part so far has been
the people who and again I'm still when
I recorded the horrible covers there's
only
there's been a lot of great cover songs
uh there's only two tracks out at the
time that I record this you know the
first two singles
but the most rewarding thing and again
this is what I said from the beginning
if one person is like ah I relate to
this like you you wrote a theme song for
my life situation or what I've been
through in this relationship
um that's been the most rewarding thing
is people
giving that feedback and saying that
like this is
you put into words
what I've been feeling and thinking and
haven't been able to say
you know and again I talked about
um
part of the inspiration for this album
being
um David bazan
Peter the lion
uh and specifically his his uh his album
curse the branches
which is obviously different musically
and different thematically but it was
like a deconstruction album from way
back in the day before I when I was in
the very beginnings of my deconstruction
uh and it was just so like I kept I
listened to that album so many times
because I was like
man people I just didn't there wasn't
enough music out there that resonated
with specifically this very difficult
thing that I was dealing with so and
more people are doing it there's more
deconstruction again I hate to use the
word it's overused but it's the best
descriptor
uh there's more and more music that
connects with the with everybody who's
experiencing this stuff I just wanted to
do my part to get it out there so thanks
for listening
do you happen to have a wreck it's your
week
um uh I guess if I had can you search
deeply I would say that I recommend that
you listen to my album
human overboard is the name of the album
James and the shame is the name of the
artist that's me
and uh it is available everywhere you
stream music and I will ask you know
it's funny I don't know what it'll be
like by the time this comes out
but I see on like on Spotify like people
also like and everybody who they also
like is like another internet famous
person who does music which I guess is
inevitable that that's what the case is
but I would just say Hey listen if this
album was your introduction to country
or Americana
uh hey there's a lot of really good
stuff out there you know I put together
that playlist a while back that was like
some of my Inspirations listen to that
music not only for your own benefit
because there's a lot of great country
music that's out there but also it'll
start to show up that people also like
country music
not Ninja Sex Party nothing against
Ninja sex party we love those guys uh
but I don't think that ninja sex party
is the greatest entry point into James
in the shame no it's not
so do some listening to train the
algorithm if you don't mind all right as
always you can call us leave us
voicemail give us your reactions we play
them at the end of every episode so
stick around for those 188 earpod one
hashtag your biscuits I written link
this is Natalie calm from Ontario I went
on my YouTube music today and it told me
that I have listened to James and the
shame
987 minutes
um which is about 16 hours
um over the course of two songs
just wanted to let you know that I love
the music and I can't wait for the rest
of the album thank you so much for
putting it out there hey guys
um first of all love the show long time
fan super stoked to hear your full album
congrats on it dude first three songs
were great love you guys thanks bye my
evening listening to your song where
we're going and bawling my eyes out I'm
36 years old my wife is 35 I have two
boys ten and eight this past Memorial
Day weekend she had a stroke
and it's been working incredibly hard in
rehab to regain the use of her left side
and various mental blocks still needless
to say this has been a whirlwind and
scary last few months my days are quite
long now keeping everything afloat and
moving forward for my boys and for her
and this song just perfectly embodies
how much I love my wife and how much I
am still just so happy to be with her
and look forward to sharing our lives
together no matter what happens along
the way I was just so moved and
compelled by this song I had to share
this with you Rhett and you know how
much your music is impacting people
thank you both for everything you give
to us and everything you share with us
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]